tonight for an investigation into
current climate advisor former secretary
of state john kerry
republicans are upset over allegations
kerry leaked israeli military secrets or
classified information
to iran state department correspondent
rich edson reports tonight much of our
discussion
he spent four years as president obama's
secretary of state
and is now president biden's climate
envoy though republicans are demanding
investigations into john kerry's time as
a private citizen during the trump
administration
and his conversations then with iran's
foreign minister
in a letter to secretary of state
anthony blinken republican senator chuck
grassley asks quote
have you begun a security inquiry and
review into secretary kerry's potential
mishandling
and improper disclosure of sensitive and
classified information
if not why not if so when did you begin
grassley also joined 18 other republican
senators requesting president biden
initiate an investigation into kerry
and suspend his security clearance a
very simple
request that we think the president
should do which is
take a look at these allegations this is
a very serious allegation
last month reports claim that iranian
foreign minister javad zarif said that
kerry revealed to him
that israel had attacked hundreds of
targets in syria
kerry maintains he never discussed those
strikes with zarif
state department officials point out
these attacks were well known
and even the israeli government publicly
acknowledged them
in an interview on cnn blinken said
quote these things were so secret that
they were all reported in the press at
the time
so it is utter nonsense and it's really
unfortunate that people continue to try
and play politics with this
other republicans have requested
investigations including those on the
house oversight committee
they want a review of kerry's security
clearance and all documents related to
his access to classified information
senator grassley is also requesting the
state department's inspector general
investigate kerry
a spokesperson says the inspector
general's office has received the
senator's letter
and has no further comment next week
republicans will get their chance to
question kerry directly he's scheduled
to testify before the house foreign
affairs committee
about the administration's climate
policies republicans say they expect to
ask him about other issues
as well brett rich we're learning about
new timeline for when the 2015 nuclear
agreement with iran
could be restored that's right during
these negotiations a senior state
department official says
that could happen in the next few weeks
though it depends on whether iran will
agree
to curb its nuclear program the official
says there are still gaps between the
u.s and iran as these negotiations
continue
opponents of the deal say they are
looking at which sanctions the biden
administration would agree to lift
remember
it was the trump administration and its
maximum pressure campaign that puts
substantial new sanctions on against
iran
those are largely still in effect brett
richettson live at the state department
rich thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else